hello everyone josh and i
well we'd like to give you something for
free that's right we got a brand new
book coming out it's called love people
use things it comes out july 13th but if
you pre-order it by june 1st
you get the free love people companion
workbook
head on over to lovepeopleusethings.net
to find all the details
i was wondering if you have a minimalist
philosophy on insurance specifically
health insurance
i'm at a point with a new job where i'm
having to choose whether i want to get
it or not
and it seems like a just-in-case type of
thing because i'm not anticipating any
major medical issues but it does
kind of feel like it'd be the smarter
option to get it
but i was wondering if you guys had any
insight or
tips to navigating insurance
and if you do i'd love to hear it so
ryan i'm told that
meredith's question is one of a dozen or
so people who called in with a very
similar question
which means thousands of people are
actually thinking this question
if a lot of people are calling in with
the same question it's a very valid
question i was just talking with a
friend this week about them
retiring and they're very their job is
stressing them out a ton
and he's an older gentleman past 65 and
i'm like why are you still working like
have you are you like not set up for
retirement he's like no actually like
i was talking to my finance guy and i've
got plenty of money in retirement
um i mean he said something about like
he could you know
set up to where he could get like six
figures a year
in retirement uh of before taxes i think
i think but regardless i'm like dude so
you're set up man
like you can totally retire what is
holding you back and he's like well you
know
i've got insurance for me and my wife
and i'm worried that you know next year
my wife has got some stuff coming up and
i don't want to have to you know
put that you know pay for that out of
pocket i'm like how much is your
insurance like how much would it be it's
like oh it's probably about 1500
a month wow i'm like so it's 18 000 a
year
for you to do this you're telling me
that your finance guy is telling you you
have
access to about six figures a year and
eighteen thousand dollars is what is
holding you back so i know that
this is kind of an anomaly uh it's an
exception but
it's just interesting how that fifteen
hundred dollars a month which he could
very
easily afford it's still uh it's still
preventing him from doing what he knows
he needs to do
yeah i think sometimes the narrative we
tell ourselves about why we're staying
behind
is only the narrative and it may not be
the complete picture
the the fear we need to put some sort of
label on the fear i'm afraid of leaving
i'm afraid of failing
and so i can the easiest thing for me to
say is the societal
acceptable thing it's healthcare because
we can all acknowledge that
our healthcare system in the united
states of america is broken
you mean our sick care system yeah yeah
and by the way we you know we
we don't focus on well-being we don't
actually focus on
health the majority of us now have
chronic
illnesses there are litany of reasons
that that exists
but be that as it may we are here right
now
and what we're recognizing is yeah
there are there's a problem with our
health care system
but that doesn't have to be as ryan
you've alluded to
that doesn't have to be the reason that
we stay stay behind and stay miserable
and so maybe if we posit it in a
different way i'm staying
miserable so that i can pay for my
health insurance
well maybe there's there's a different
way and that different way quite often
is
how much is it going to cost me because
this ultimately just becomes
part of my budget when you and i walked
away from the corporate world it was
like
okay our insurance is about 350 bucks a
month
right well that's just part of my every
month
budget it's there with rent and
utilities and now
health insurance now jack patreon
doesn't give us health insurance do that
maybe am i missing out on something here
not yet do you guys do
oh oh wow i mean i
look i th the fact that
benefits are tied to the employer
right now yeah um and what that means
for this emerging creative class who
doesn't have a traditional employer
yes that's got to be fixed right it will
be fixed somebody's going to fix that
because it's nonsense yes yeah so maybe
patreon
is going to be the place where creatives
can go
to get their benefits in the meantime i
think what we need to understand
meredith
if i look at your question here and what
you're really saying is how do i
navigate this
complex world of insurance it's
overwhelming yeah
and it's not overwhelming for you right
now because mommy and daddy the employer
they take care of it for you right and
and so do you need it she's also asking
is it a just in case item
or is it just for win item or an
emergency item let's talk so we we
we have these 16 rules for a living with
less and
i just mentioned three of them there one
is just in case items we call the 2020
rule anything i'm holding on to just in
case you know all those cables are
sitting in your junk drawer
you can replace for less than 20 in less
than 20 minutes wherever you are
and that frees up space to get rid of
tens of thousands of just in case items
the good news is
you never have to use the rule all those
things we hold on to just in case we
never
ever use and you know because you have a
studio and so
there's a lot of just in case items
there you're like wow this is from 1993
and it's been sitting here ever since
now there are
these just in case items that ryan and i
say okay it does make sense to hold on
to they're emergency items yeah
they're the just in case items you hope
you never ever have to use my first aid
kit
is it just in case out the but it's an
emergency item the spare tire on my car
i don't want to use it but it's there
just in case i absolutely need it so
emergency items are the sort of one
subset of just the case on as we set
aside
we call it the emergency item rule and
then there are these other things that
are just for win
items i think health insurance is sort
of a combination depending on
your health status it's either an
emergency item where you're like okay
i'm i have that in case some sort of
catastrophe happens right
and then i will have access to health
care then you had just have catastrophic
coverage that's what ryan and i have and
so if some sort of catastrophe happens i
end up in the emergency room
something's broken whatever uh i can
handle it very high deductible
now there could be a case where there's
just for win
you know if you are a type 1 diabetic
for example you need medication every
month you would then
you need insurance just for when or
you're going to be paying out of pocket
every single month either way that needs
to become part of the budgeting and yes
i think our system
and our costs are skyrocketing they're
out of control
medical debt is responsible for more
um people being financially bankrupt
than just about anything else at this
point
it's a huge problem but in order for it
to not be a problem in our own lives
it just becomes part of our budget so we
understand that if i'm a business owner
if i'm a creator
and i want health insurance well then
i'm going to have to plan for that just
like
i'm going to plan for rent or you know
whatever other expenses i have in my
life
yeah it's so funny i'm like thinking of
a few different solutions to
people who uh need insurance who can't
afford to pay for it outright on their
own every month like one thing
i'm thinking about is i know that let's
say
you go to the emergency room like you
you know god forbid you have an
emergency
you don't have insurance you go there um
that you get this huge er bill
if you don't have the income you know
there's a certain level of income if you
don't make that
uh that will get subsidized i'm not
encouraging people to go and take
advantage of you know
like uh of of subsidizing your medical
bills i mean that's not what i'm saying
but there are options for emergency type
situations like that another another
thing too like i asked my friend
who i was having this conversation with
about retirement i'm like dude how much
a year would you pay
to not have this stress like is it worth
the 18 000 a year and he's like yeah
like you put it that way like i would
definitely
you know as long as you can afford it so
um so yeah i mean
you know ask yourself uh meredith like
what is it worth for you
to go out on your own uh yeah if you
have to pay an extra 300 bucks a month
for your insurance it's a lot of money
but maybe it's worth
um taking that stress away another thing
i was thinking too is like there's
there's medicare right i mean it's not
it's not the best insurance in the world
but it is
is it medicare medicaid medicare right
medicaid if you're over 65 i believe
right yeah so medicare i mean i know
people i know uh
i have friends who are starving artists
and that's what they're on no it's not
the best
option for insurance it's not this
cadillac insurance but when they get
sick they have something to fall back on
so it's not um i just don't want
meredith here to feel completely
hopeless i mean there are
some things that uh yeah maybe it's not
as good as the insurance you have right
now but there certainly are options that
you can look at um
outside of you know what your employer
pays for you it seems like maybe there's
a difference in
with you know between just in case items
the difference between a cable
you know and health insurance is that
the risk associated with not having a
cable when you need it is very small
right the risk associated with not
having health insurance when you need it
it could be catastrophic
and that's why it's an emergency yes
that's why i look at it as one of those
things that is
absolutely necessary and in fact um what
i will tell you is that because of
patreon and we've found a number that
works for us monetarily
we're going to make sure so we see sean
and jordan here we also have jess on our
team
uh we're going to make sure everyone has
health insurance once we reach a certain
number
of patrons so that we can afford to pay
for health insurance for everyone on the
team as well
pamplemoose is actually doing that right
now we're just going through health
benefits
that's beautiful so so giving patreon is
in a way giving us opportunity
keeping the podcast 100 advertisement
free but still being able to
you know we always joke that this
episode of minimalist is brought to you
by nobody because advertisements suck
but the truth is
it's brought to you by you patrons
and it's brought to everyone by the few
people who are willing to support
and i know podcast shawn and his entire
family he has i don't know 13 kids or
something
who knows how many kids jordan has um he
doesn't even know
yeah yeah he claims none on his taxes
right
but yeah what we've learned is like hey
we want to be able to provide that as
well as a as a sort of benefit
to to the team to say thank you so thank
you to the patrons
for supporting us and providing that as
well amen it's amazing
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists today
your support keeps our podcast and
youtube channel 100
advertisement free